avec aurélie all n y ont élu république
souveraine à villemoirieu spécialiste
des questions de santé et aussi fade il
amellal ancienne conseillère de paris
élue au du xviiie présidente fondatrice
des mariannes de la diversité c'est
notre débat ce soir
bonsoir mesdames merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation comment est-ce
qu'il faut l'interpréter absence des
pouvoirs publics ça ne bouge pas assez
vite fadila mehal
je voulais d'abord dire que c'est pas
une question qui peut se résoudre avec
une baguette magique ça va prendre plus
tôt c'est un vrai débat parce qu'il ya
une véritable hostilité aux rides des
riverains finalement sur 7 sur ses sales
mais en même temps vous voyez bien que
l'exemple et moi vous savez je suis
quelqu'un de très pragmatique je n'ai
pas d'idéologie en la matière quand
j'étais élu du xviiie je vais chercher à
comprendre comment avait fonctionné
finalement les pays européens où il faut
quand même savoir qu'à plus de six pays
a le canada et l'australie qui ont mis
en place ces salles de shoot et c'est
vrai déjà le terme ici en français et
est vraiment très négatif puisque on
parle de salles de shoot alors qu'il
s'agit finalement de salles de
consommation à moindre risque donc c'est
quand même cette question là qui est
posée et les retours d'expérience que
nous avons eues que nous avons tous
c'est qu'en effet il ya eu quand même
des choses très positives il ya plus de
soixante deux centres qui ont été créés
à l'échelle européenne et je pense que
depuis 2000 d'ailleurs et nous avons le
recul nécessaire pour savoir ce qui
marche et ce qui ne marche pas alors ce
qui marche c'est qu' il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de l'utilisation des
drogues puisque finalement toute la
prise de drogue elle se fait par des
initiés que ça n'a pas ramené d'autres
personnes il y a eu un impact très
positif sur les tragiques pratiques
d'injection puisqu'il ya quand même des
problèmes de sécurité avec du matériel
propre est lui relativement sécurisé et
c'est vrai que l se fondre de bonnes
conditions sanitaires et puis il faut
savoir aussi que nous souhaitions
toucher les populations les plus
marginalisées
et c'est vrai que la laque c est quand
même plus favorable alors évidemment il
reste des doutes il reste notamment ce
que j'ai et j'entendais dans le
reportage le fait que ce soient des
lieux en effet qu'ils puissent être
absolument à la tu ne sois pas proximité
de jeunes ou de structures scolaires
mais je pense très honnêtement qu'il
faut considérer la toxicomanie comme une
maladie et ce sont d'abord des patients
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des problèmes
d'insécurité on l'a vu dans le xviiie et
évidemment avec le jardin d'eole on l'a
compris que la sécurité était à une fois
maîtresse pour les riverains il ya eu
même rappelez-vous des viols en direct
des oreilles de jeter ça dit la mea l'on
va donner on va on va demander justement
aurait les aulagnon ce qu'elle pense du
bilan global que l'on peut faire
concernant l'utilité de ces salles de
shoot le ter aussi ce que vous êtes
d'accord vous avec fadila mehal alors je
partage le regard de madame mais elle
alors effectivement le terme salles de
shoot et est terrible c'est très
stigmatisant l faut vraiment parler de
salles de consommation à moindre risque
il ya deux ans je hais les enjeux
sanitaires et n'en déplaise à la
personne qui a parti qui a parlé dans le
reportage précédent c'est déjà un
dispositif de soins on parle de patients
on parle d'usagé du service de soins il
ya ce côté là sanitaire qui est pour
consommer de manière beaucoup plus
sereine ilian ne parle pas de lieu de
vente on est bien d'accord le but du jeu
c'est de travailler sur les épidémies
sur les maladies des transmissions sur
créer un dialogue avec les personnes qui
consomment et les faire entrer dans un
parcours de soins et de sevrage en lien
avec les ex à part les cas rude tout
tout le système qui existe déjà ça c'est
le premier aspect il ya un aspect qui
est aussi en plus du duo en plus de
l'aspect sanitaire à l'aspect de
politique publique territoriale où
justement on est sur la tranquillité 1
c'était à l'origine
la démarche pourquoi est-ce qu'on a un
sale et installer ses serres c'est aussi
pour pour essayer d'installer la
tranquillité dans ces quartiers où ça
consomme héroïne crack cocaïne et
compagnie donc on a ces deux aspects
learn à l'aspect sanitaire qui
effectivement quelque chose de national
et on a l'aspect tranquillité des
riverains qui va être un aspect local et
du coup on est sur ces deux enjeux là et
on est on connaît tous un le cas de tout
le monde ceux qui râlent sur les
voitures qui passent vite dans le rue
mais personne ne veut le ralentisseur
dents devant chez soi on est sur le même
niveau
clairement il ça demande un
accompagnement et je rejoins malade mais
à un accompagnement aussi local avec les
riverains avec les consommateurs avec
les associations justement cet
accompagnement des riverains on a le
sentiment quand on écoute ses riverains
que l'on a entendu il y en a pas
justement d'accompagnement puisqu'ils se
disent abandonnés par les pouvoirs
publics va dire mais alain
non mais je ne peux pas eu d'accord
puisque vous voyez bien qu'il ya une
volonté à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
points de fixation parce que c'est ça le
problème qui amène en effet une
massification un peu d'aidé des
toxicomanes la première des réponses a
été de déplacés mais c'est pas c'est une
réponse à court terme à long terme il
faut réfléchir finalement à la politique
de prévention que nous voulons
d'avoir et c'est vrai que je partage
complètement ce que disait aurélie c'est
à dire que c'est d'abord des patients
c'est d'abord des malades c'est d'avoir
des jours qu'il faut soigner et ça ne
peut pas être un lieu de consommation
c'est un lieu aussi d'hébergement et
donc je considère que c'est cette
question vous savez elle est tellement
difficile et c'est un des points de
retour d expérience et qui a une très
grande hostilité par rapport à ces
questions et notamment des riverains
donc je pense qu'il ya soutenant les
riverains de nouvelles blagues salles de
shoot dans les lieux habités
[Musique]
mais regardons mais quand on mettait en
place les foyers d'hébergement après
vous d'urgence ou même des foyers de
travailleurs d'immigrés personne n'en
voulait pas ce qu'on disait ça fait
tomber le prix de ma maison mais à un
moment donné il faut que l'intérêt
général c'est pour ça que le lieu il
doit être extrêmement pensé réfléchi
avec l'adhésion d'un maximum de rivera
et mais en même temps il je pense qu'il
faut qu'on réfléchisse maintenant très
sérieusement compte tenu de la
massification de cette question avec le
cra et que aujourd'hui en personne leur
offrir la colline du crack aurélie
aulagnon vous soulignez vous un manque
de pédagogie finalement dans ce conflit
entre les riverains les pouvoirs publics
exactement tout à fait vous touchez du
doigt quelque chose c'est à dire que
yann étude de l'inserm à qui vient de
sortir de mai 2021 qu'est vraiment toute
récente et qui montre justement que tout
l'intérêt de ces salles de consommation
ça diminue cela divise par trois le
nombre de traces de consommation à
proximité des deux c'est sale ça montre
vraiment
l'accompagnement les personnes les
français sont pour les seules les salles
de consommation à moindre risque donc on
remet pas en cause les faits les
indicateurs ont prouvé que c'est
efficace maintenant on a cette donnée là
qu'est ce qu'on en fait on en est là on
est sûr de la politique d'accompagnement
il ya de la pédagogie mais c'est de la
prévention on est en france ont
malheureusement on est parent pauvre la
prévention des parents pauvres pour une
fois qui en a il va falloir
l'accompagner il va falloir budgétisé et
malheureusement ça repose un petit peu
trop sur les collectivités locales et on
doit accompagner sa quels sont les
moyens qui sont données pour encadrer
les riverains c'est pour ça je vous
disais tout à l'heure il faut mettre
tout le monde autour de la table
effectivement il ya aussi la question de
pourquoi alors là ça a été choisi de les
mettre dans les lieux de consommation on
peut aussi envisager comme à strasbourg
à strasbourg c'est au coeur d'un hôpital
l'avantagent on a le côté soins qui du
coup la pédagogie et déjà fait puisque
les salles de consommation à moindre
risque et dans un hôpital ça permet
ainsi de traiter les overdoses mortelles
beaucoup plus rapidement enfin mortels
justement avant qu'elles soient mortels
ça permet de les traiter et de faire ce
lien sous 1 pourquoi à ce moment là ne
pas envisager ça comme ça pourquoi en
tout cas il faut aussi interrogé les
personnes les usagers de ces produits là
pour voir quelles sont aussi leurs
attentes pour pouvoir les accompagner
sereinement dans le chemin du sevrage je
partage je partage complètement votre
point de vue vous savez j'étais une élue
à la fois du modem et de la reine et à
chaque fois que nous sommes intervenus
nous groupes politiques au sein de
l'assemblée du conseil de paris on a
toujours dit que il était préférable en
effet que ces structures soient adossées
à un établissement hospitalier ça c'est
une évidence ça peut pas toujours se
faire mais c'est vrai que c'est la
meilleure santé mais pourquoi ça peut
pas toujours safar justement fadila
mehal bah écoutez moi je ne connais pas
les tenants puisque vous l'avez compris
que nous étions dans l'opposition
mais ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui
c'est que visiblement il ya un consensus
entre
quatre lieux qui devrait avoir lieu à
paris donc à la fois dans le dans le
xème le 19ème et le 20ème arrondissement
et donc avec des impératifs vous l'avez
dit de sécurité pour que ces zones en
effet ne n'apporte pas plus de nuisances
et que même ce qu'il faut veiller c'est
que toutes ces nuisances soient diminués
et d'ailleurs plusieurs études vous
l'avez rappelé montrent qu'il ya une
diminution des actes de délinquance aux
alentours des 100 après leur
implantation quand ils sont ils pas
évidemment convenablement gérer alors
aurélie aulagnon outre les salles de
shoot comment est-ce qu'il faut
accompagner les toxicomanes
ça c'est une question elle est
accompagnée alors les toxicos mecs sont
des malades avant tout il faut pas
oublier les salles de consommation
permettent déjà les accompagne et vous
avez les mecs sympas les cas rudent qui
sont deux systèmes différents
d'accompagnement avec des travailleurs
sociaux qui mettant les travailleurs
sociaux qui met en lien aussi les
soignants et des services d'hébergement
pour accompagner ces personnes là
l'intérêt que je peux voir à long terme
aussi sur les salles de consommation à
la possibilité de tester les produits
testés les produits que vont consommer
ces personnes ça permet de voir avec
quoi ils peuvent être coupés avec
notamment le fentanyl qui est terrible
ça permet ainsi essayez de voir un petit
peu les réseaux qui sont créés et
essayer de prévenir ces personnes on a
aussi cet accompagnement par la
consommation des produits essayer de
leur éviter de consommer des produits
qui sont vraiment encore plus dangereux
pour eux ça me ça me paraît être
important volet sur le volet du malaise
social
pousse justement ces toxicomanes à aa a
consommé du crack fadila mehal justement
est-ce qu'il faut pas aller au delà et
est aussi prendre des mesures à ce
niveau
quant à l'insertion sociale
voilà pas simplement d'insertion sociale
mais moi je pense que comme vous l'avez
rappelé les conduites addictives sont
une maladie et donc on ne peut pas se
rassurer en disant on va multiplier les
salles de shoot ou que les conditions
d'accès finalement la drogue soit la
plus propre et la plus sauf il faut en
effet travaillé sur cette question qui
est fondamentale c'est comment on met en
place une politique pour désintoxiquer
parce que c'est quand même la halle à
terme je veux dire à long terme c'est
quand même la pratique la plus sécure
aujourd'hui c'est de sortir nos jeunes
et de moins jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
ces pratiques addictives pour qu'il
puisse sortir de ça donc ça ne peut être
qu'en parallèle finalement ces salles de
consommation à moindre risque parce que
l'idéal est l'objectif et l'horizon
synthes de les sortir de ces conduites
addictives je sais que c'est pas simple
parce qu'il ya des raisons
multifactorielle à la fois des questions
sociales à la fois de détresse en plus
avec le confinement je peux vous assurer
que on l'a vu une recrudescence aussi
très très importante par rapport à ces
conduites addictives mais en même temps
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
réfléchir c'est pour ça qu'il faut
réfléchir globalement ne pas dire c'est
la panacée ces salles qui vont se
multiplier
merci beaucoup à vous faire la main à
l'ancien compère de paris et du xviiie
est et présidente fondatrice de marianne
de la diversité merci également à vous
aurélie aulagnon il une république
souveraine a vu mario et spécialiste des
questions de santé